hello ahead welcome to this video
playing max even let's see maybe a trump
I haven't played this for a while edge
the change of pace and ok I'm going to
take and play is that one of those maybe
I can go with this g3 strategy g3 and so
on ok probably have to write how to play
without b3 here Quincy one looks a
little bit passive hmm how interesting
if I go Bishop g2 now Bishop before
checkers is quite annoying actually do I
have to play Bishop d3 boom yeah g3
looks a little bit silly than regardless
but probably have to yeah it's not a big
deal ok
so this looks a little bit wrong hit
everything yet maybe I can shoot for a
night afore he allows that it's nice
hmm various very real position I played
some very stranger probably bad news Wow
but is it so bad that you can play g5
that I'd I have some doubts about hmm
how to play this and Knight to f5 would
be brilliant of course but ok I'm
starting with this now
yeah I think I'll do this just make sure
you never place the f porn I mean it's
very likely he cannot do any way it can
be there anyway but he I'm absolutely
sure and so after him I'd like to place
your forearm but I am kind of I don't
1c5 and I want that that opening of the
position early on but will you really
play that I don't I don't think so
actually see if I can take the five CD
494 it could be just good for white but
yeah I mean if he allows oh yeah he
allows that he allows to capture on d5
so this is clean very very nice of
course check air pollution strategically
very nice for white so let's see you in
his his pawns I very Regan and I 27 has
a very bad bad spot so a chair didn't
quite clearly better him
and the most important thing is the pawn
structure though so yeah here this is
the thing night c5 huh might be might be
okay I think I do that straight pin
trade nights so that i can actually
attack the f6 phone and the d5 pawn from
real
check so go back here rook takes d4 now
is there's a threat so let's go over
here still don't see him playing at five
this is important
okay I'm probably here okay if i move
the Queen away I'm threatening f3 as
well any other way forward not sure
probably not I probably have to operate
with that f3 adium and it worked Oh clam
if it takes g4 I have to check the roof
immediately I cannot take age takes g4s
got king and queen f6 to pin so i lack
resigns you know it wasn't necessary
really add any more at the end I mean
I'm always better here due to the
structure but it was certainly something
that that he could continue to fight
check so here I mean queen d 6 or
something like that it's always a bit a
bit uncomfortable for black but he does
not necessarily have to lose quickly
absolutely not so yeah you should have
look at that weird opening somehow
somehow that didn't work out I mean
there is a set up with g3 Bishop g2 but
after Bishop at five now I cannot play
that yeah he's got the check check and
this is a bit awful I mean I don't want
to want that to happen and 0 and C 3
takes here and I'm losing a pawn mmm so
yeah at the end i went down i don't
think it is that bad it just looks looks
very strange so and that this is a weird
move i think i'm not sure if he wants to
push the night away you can go bishop v6
and i probably have to have to move it
anyway and now this is this is weakening
quite quite a lot so always a little bit
afraid that you would push see 5 or
something like that but i don't think it
works like this this this a thought
should be should be okay for me probably
is the engine is on equal but yes i
think i should be better check the
computer gives the interesting move c5
that's it's very interesting
check and equality check no it's
probably true he is getting rid of its
25 weakness and he okay the computer
just takes d5 yeah I didn't even
consider the move but okay it has also
not bad not bad at all what you can
argue about is certainly around here
that 95 north maybe this is to
simplifying I mean his night is not in a
good shape but I thought that it would
isn't my what is my task this is however
what the engine gives and that looks
pretty strong because it prevents group
d 8 as well and I just hangs and then
rooks he talks he won't air that is
stronger than 95 he probably I mean he
is still worse but it's not not as
problematic maybe as it could have been
yeah he was kind enough to return to let
his room trapped only form otherwise it
would have been a far far tougher task
okay well thanks for watching